Why does the world need the new weekly publication covering Asian business?
Because there are stories in Asia that are yet to be told.
Stories that will transform the way we do business and the way we live.
There are stories that are only told to locals, stories that cross borders,...
...stories that connect one side of Asia to another in ways that are not always obvious.
We're here to tell those stories.
With reporters on the ground and more locations across Asia...
...than any other business publication,...
...and with a network of contributors, that includes captains of industry, academics,...
...and political leaders from across the region,...
...all backed by Nikkei's extensive editorial unit in Tokyo,...
...this English language publication would bring you analysis and insights from Asia...
...from the inside out, in print, on our website and our new tablet and mobile device.
So, when it comes to business in Asia, see what others don't.
Nikkei Asian Review.